d'un bout à l'autre du pays
les cérémonies ont eu lieu aujourd'hui
pour souligner l'héritage des peuples
autochtones l'éducation la
sensibilisation se passe la main plus
importants pour combattre le racisme
dans les attaques comme et j'espère
qu'aujourd'hui pourra contribuer sur une
journée importante notamment pour ne pas
oublier les horreurs vécues dans les
pensionnats autochtones
on entend les disques aujourd'hui des
survivants des pensionnats qui commence
à parler d'eux c'est comme si on les
entendait merisier coup de poing à
ottawa l'une des recommandations du
comité vérité et réconciliation a
récemment été appliquée en juin le
parlement a adopté à l'unanimité le
projet de loi c 5 qui crée la journée
nationale pour la vérité et la
réconciliation
elle aura lieu le 30 septembre ce sera
au départ un congé férié pour pour les
employés fédéraux pour que notre société
reconnaît que le plus possible avec avec
cette réalité avec les traditions mais
aussi avec les peuples autochtones au
canada le premier ministre du québec
n'envisage pas d'imiter le fédéral
écoutez on n'est pas en faveur d'ajouter
des journées fériées pour quelques
raisons que ce soit au québec on a un or
toutes proportions gardées déjà beaucoup
si le gouvernement du québec veut
démontrer une certaine ouverture envers
les peuples autochtones démontre
également l'heure était à la
réconciliation
ça serait la moindre des choses à
pouvoir adapter une journée fériée en
l'honneur des peuples autochtones les
territoires du nord-ouest et le uk ont
déjà décrété que la journée nationale
des autochtones du 21 juin serait férié
sur leur territoire ici julie aimant
radio canada montréal